spider-man's marvel cinematic universe
journey began way back in 2016 as part
of the ensemble film captain america
civil war in the years since he has
found great success and failure
certainly doing more than previous
live-action incarnations of the web
slinger ever had a chance to he's gone
toe to toe with earthbound supervillains
face down the mad titan thanos in a bid
to save the universe and even came back
from beyond the grave however spider-man
no way home presented him with arguably
his biggest challenge yet in the mcu
following a magical multiverse
collapsing mishap courtesy of doctor
strange several iconic spider-man
villains poured into the main mcu
timeline standouts from sam raimi's
spider-man trilogy green goblin dr auto
octavius and sandman returned to the
silver screen but that's not all foes
from mark webb's amazing spider-man
films reemerged as well those being the
lizard and electro the latter got quite
the makeover this time around but
simultaneously left fans scratching
their heads by the time the credits
rolled the mcu spider-man 3 cool was a
mind-bending continuity-straining event
and while it was a ton of fun to
reconnect with all the old heroes and
villains it did result in a few
confusing moments fans will likely be
unpacking all the various plot conflicts
created by no way home for a generation
but there's one in particular that we
just can't shake there's a big
electro-related plot hole in no way home
here's what it is as noted previously
the reason why so many spider-man rogues
from across time and space converged on
the mcu earth had to do with dr
strange's botched spell as he tried to
magically force the world to forget that
peter parker is spider-man the wall
crawler in question keeps talking and
breaking his focus seems like tom
holland has trouble keeping quiet in any
reality as a result strange's cast went
haywire and before he could contain it a
few sinister bad guys slipped through
the cracks according to the former
sorcerer supreme the flood brought over
people who knew that peter parker and
spider-man were one and the same that
goes a long way toward explaining the
rogue's gallery that our spidey trifecta
had to face off against but there is one
outlier here this concept makes sense
for all of the villains except elektro
fans of the garfield starring the
amazing spider-man flicks will likely
recall that fox's electrified baddie
never actually learned his spidey secret
identity during his sole previous
appearance in the amazing spider-man 2.
perhaps this little detail simply
slipped through the cracks there is a
lot of continuity to wrangle after all
but electro's ignorance of spider-man's
identity actually made it into the
script the villain addresses it
explicitly in no way home when he
mentions that he always thought
spider-man was black so what's really
going on here the easy answer is that
marvel studios and sony simply wanted to
play to the fans and give jamie foxx
another chance to portray max dillon as
for in-universe explanations fans have
begun to pull some ideas together to
explain this plot hole away which is
awfully generous of them referring to a
line by letro and no way home concerning
what he was doing before he jumped to
the mcu one redditor posted assuming
strange was right about the spell
perhaps max absorbed some data that gave
him spider-man's identity another user
also brings up an interesting idea in
the same reddit thread stating most
likely the villains of no way home were
pulled from universes that have history
extremely similar to but not quite
identical to the events of the raimi and
web spider-man movies octavius's
inability to recognize his friend kirk
connors as the lizard and sandman
constantly maintaining his sandy state
totally flying in the face of their
rainy incarnations lend credence to this
theory there's also the solution that a
few people brought up claiming that
perhaps strange didn't fully understand
the spell or misinterpreted in some way
there's also the timeless answer that
electro slipped into the mcu because
comics are crazy and any attempt to
explain away every little asynchronous
detail is a fool's errand regardless of
the true answer we can only hope that
somehow a future mcu installment will
put this electro plot hole to bed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
no way home are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]